i will say
i heard joe rogan uh joe rogan was
trending
last night and this morning um as a
result of people being dismayed at
things he had
said on his podcast of course and as is
so frequently the case when you go and
check
a joe is not did not say the things that
he has reported to have said
and b the things that people imagine
were so upsetting shouldn't have been
upsetting to them one of the things that
joe said was something very much like
what you and i have been planning to say
here about these other interventions
and the fact that it's weird that we're
not recommending them
um but the thing joe got in trouble for
most precipitously was
he was claimed he it was
argued that he said on this podcast
that um the vaccines might be
causing mutations in the virus
right which is an odd thing for him to
have said and when you go and look at
what he actually said he never said
anything of the sort in fact what he did
was he read a he read from a paper
that argued that the vaccines might
select
for mutants that would be more dangerous
or more transmissible which is a totally
defensible
and highly logical thing for him to have
said so in any case there's some weird
phenomenon where
the simple fact of you know joe rogan
speaking common sense is so dangerous
that he needs to be strong and online
and he needs to trend for
you know supposed villainy um when in
fact what he's saying are things that
should be obvious to anyone
you know there clearly is a hazard that
comes from the selective environment
that we are creating for this virus
there clearly is a lost opportunity
in not recommending to people that hey
there are certain things that are under
your control
that you're maybe not doing and you
don't realize may be playing a very
large role in whether or not you're
vulnerable
to covid come january right so
there's some there's some failure of our
discussion that's so
fundamental um that we're just we're
missing opportunities that are obviously
there and should be completely
uncontroversial
right indeed does the disaster of
merrick's disease in chickens due to
leaky vaccines
relate to covert vaccines in any way
would this have been prevented if they
didn't vaccinate the chickens
yes we don't know whether it relates to
our covet situation it's too early to
tell
right i mean we talked about it
we talked about the paper that did that
research um
it's from like 2015 i think um both
on the podcast and in the paper in our
paper um
with regard to providing some empirical
evidence
that this this is understood to be an
outcome at least sometimes
when you mass vaccinate with a leaky
vaccine um
when a disease is in this case i think
endemic rather than pandemic but
the distinction may be um not important
here
um would this have been preventative
they didn't vaccinate the chickens and i
think
you know difference between merrick's
disease and covid
is that as terrible as covet is the um
you know the fatality rate the case
fatality rate is not nearly as high like
merrick's to see is just like
wipes through populations as i
understand it i think well
with a caveat okay uh the caveat being
these were domestic chickens
yeah um and domestic chickens are
a unique critter among other things
they have had their telomeres elongated
um
by of course they must have but do you
know that yeah i do
okay um but it's it's like successful
just by the same breeding protocol as
elongated the telomeres of the lab mice
right presumably it's the same thing we
don't know for sure
but yeah that we don't know um but
so merrick's disease is a neoplastic
virus a rare virus that causes cancers
these creatures are likely to be cancer
prone
no i didn't know it was neoplastic right
so anyway the point is
uh with the caveat the chickens are not
a good model for anything by virtue of
their distortion
yeah through their breeding process who
knows but
the idea that we are dealing with an
issue of
um driving escape mutants with leaky
vaccines
possible ade you know these things are
on the table
and what merrick's disease has to tell
us is uh proceed with caution because
welcome to complex systems
yeah yeah and just i mean just let's be
clear so you you know in the first hour
first hour and a half you were talking
about the way that joe rogan has been
um strawmanned and said to say things he
didn't say and i think the quote that
you read or
suggested that um he said that
vaccinations
um create mutants right cause mutation
cause mutation which did not say which i
i see that
cause mutation could be equilib you know
equalized to create mutants and
the selective pressure which you just
said correctly but
could be misunderstood by those who
weren't paying careful attention or who
wanted to misconstrue
don't get the difference or let's just
like who don't you know it's it's a
little subtle
right that there will you know all these
viruses
are are replicating and they've all got
variation
in them right right and so the mutations
are happening regardless
and if you've got a va if you've got a
selective pressure in the form of a
vaccine that's now coming in and going
on some number of them you know those
those
things that already exist those mutants
those mutations that already exist in
the population
that for whatever reason aren't um
you know aren't coverable by the vaccine
will be more likely to thrive it's not
that the vaccine created them
they already existed but they will grow
in abundance relative to the other
strains
if they are not susceptible to the
selective pressure which is the vaccine
right but from the point of view
of what joe rogan said he said and he
was just reading a paper but the point
was
the vaccines select for these things
right
that's neither here they're rare like i
just thought that this was an important
obviously joe rogan didn't say the thing
that they said and you didn't say the
thing that people will misread is you
just having said
i think it's important for us to as many
times as possible
be very clear about what is actually
meant because
you know there's now papers out that
seem to say this with regard to covid in
which some of the authors of those
papers even are like oh no no
you know definitely there won't be any
selective pressure and you hear them
talking you think
you don't you don't actually understand
how evolution works yeah
and um we i i just this this wasn't
about joe rogan it was just like
reminding us i know but i'm i'm involved
in that exact discussion at this moment
and it is important to be clear it's the
selection
that is the consequence of the vaccine
so why don't you again so i've just said
it clearly why don't you again say it
clearly just let me have it as many
times
as possible the hypothesis
is that the vaccines create immunity
that then select
for some variants right so mutation
makes
changes it is not creates
right presumably uh mutation is random
it doesn't have to be but that's the
presumption of
almost every model and selection
exerted by the immune system on a leaky
vaccine a on a breakthrough case that
results from a leaky vaccine
will be for those variants that are most
invisible to the immune system which
will then
likely be invisible to the next
vaccinated person's immune system too
because it's the same immunity that is
[Music]
induced
you